[Música]
ah
buenas tardes hoy vengo hablarles de una
idea de una idea que es bastante simple
pero sin embargo me ha acompañado
durante muchos años y realmente me ha
sido de mucha utilidad
me acompaña desde que soy adolescente yo
vengo de una pequeña ciudad de salta
llamada de general güemes
y recuerdo estar terminando el
secundario caminando por las calles de
mi ciudad pensando en lo que me iba a
deparar la vida
me voy a ir bien
qué carrera voy a elegir
voy a tener éxito voy a ser feliz voy a
quedarme en salda voy a ir
y por supuesto ahora abrumado con todas
estas cuestiones tan típicas de esta
etapa de nuestras vidas lo único que
pedía era tener una oportunidad una
oportunidad en la cual pueda realmente
demostrar de lo que era capaz pueda dar
todo de mí y producir un cambio
pasó el tiempo y tuve la suerte ganar
una muy linda beca para estudiar
ingeniería eléctrica en buenos aires
tuve que cambiar mi pequeña ciudad por
las calles buenos aires lo que es el
colegio por la universidad y a pesar de
todos los cambios que había en ese
momento de mi vida ese día se llama fija
pero con una gran diferencia que la fui
entendiendo poco a poco ya fui
profundizando
y hoy para que ustedes entiendan
la podemos expresar con dos preguntas
cuál va a ser mi legado aquí
qué huella voy a ser capaz de dejar
como les comenté soy ingeniero eléctrico
me dedico a eso con lo cual mi punto de
vista está un poco sesgado por mi
profesión así que les quiero mostrar
algunos ejemplos pensemos cómo es el
consumo típico de argentina un día como
hoy un día de invierno de 0 a 24 horas
cuando consumimos más electricidad
cuando consumimos menos
en la madrugada estamos todos durmiendo
estamos con la luces apagadas no hay
mucha actividad hasta que se acercan las
6 7 de la mañana nos levantamos
prendemos las luces se hace frío a la
calefacción la apaga para tomar unos
mates los del pelo largo se plancha en
el pelo etcétera empieza nuestra vida
empieza el país a moverse
pasa nuestro día llegamos a la tarde y
se viene ese glorioso momento de la
noche donde nos sacamos los zapatos
y nos sentamos a ver la novela de las
nueve hace frío prendió una calefacción
aprendimos el microondas prendemos el
horno eléctrico entonces el momento de
mayor consumo de un día de invierno es a
esta hora a las 9 de la noche
aproximadamente en verano la cosa es muy
similar con la única diferencia de que
no usamos calefacción y por el contrario
nos venimos de calor con lo cual
prendemos los aires acondicionados los
ventiladores
y la curva el punto máximo de consumo se
desplaza al momento de mayor calor tipo
3 la tarde
bien ahora que todos somos más o menos
expertos en leer curvas de demanda
eléctrica del país voy a dejar que
ustedes adivinen el siguiente ustedes me
digan qué pasó en estos dos días les voy
a mostrar un gráfico que en realidad son
dos días que se sintetizan en un solo
gráfico porque el comportamiento fue
similar
qué pasó en argentina que estábamos
haciendo pensemos un 21 de junio y un 30
de junio a las 3 de la tarde los que
estamos en el trabajo lo que estábamos
en la universidad lo que estábamos en
nuestras casas que estábamos haciendo
todo el mundial estábamos cuando
argentina el 21 de junio argentina
estaba jugando el partido en agua
inaugural de nuestra selección contra
islandia y el 30 de junio nos estábamos
cuando la clasificación contra nigeria
miren la huella que dejamos miren lo que
pasó en el consumo eléctrico a las 3 de
la tarde más o menos nos juntamos en la
casa de alguno apagamos las luces de la
nuestra y nos concentramos en ese
televisor el país literalmente se detuvo
fije en el poco consumo que tenemos
pasaron los 40 y primeros 45 minutos nos
levantamos estirar las piernas prendemos
las luces abrimos la heladera vamos a
poner más más agua a calentar para
seguir tomando mates
para el segundo tiempo y desde 1 tiempo
se ve exactamente lo mismo si el país se
detuvo hasta que bueno termine el
partido y cada uno siguió con su vida
cotidiana
miren lo que fuimos capaces de dejar
la huella que fuimos capaces de dejar
en el consumo eléctrico de nuestro país
sin ponernos de acuerdo si siquiera
enterarnos de eso
imagínense lo que seríamos capaces de
lograr
si nos ponemos de acuerdo por lo menos
para hacer una cosa mínima una cosa
chiquitita el impacto que podemos llegar
a producir en el país
es increíble
por ahí
y ustedes me ven a mí diciendo
ojalá que pase mostrando un mostrándole
una expresión de deseo y la realidad es
que está pasando el mundo se puso de
acuerdo y hay un montón de políticas
energéticas que fomentan los consumos
más eficientes de electricidad agua luz
gas y hay un montón de países que se
juntaron a discutir ya tratar los
problemas del impacto ambiental que
estamos teniendo ya muchos países se
comprometieron a reducir el impacto que
producen
cada vez en la generación de fuentes
energéticas se está aumentando más y más
hoy en día el 18 por ciento de la
energía que consumimos en el mundo
proviene de fuentes renovables eso es
mucho y por ahí uno pensará bueno me
encanta que se pongan de acuerdo me
encanta que estemos haciendo algo y
seguramente son los países catalogados
de primer mundo lo que le da bien
eeuu muchos países de europa
pero no hace falta ir tan lejos nuestros
queridos vecinos uruguayos en 2005
hicieron un acuerdo multipartidista de
planeación energética que quiere decir
esto que entre todos los partidos
políticos se pusieron de acuerdo y
dijeron ok
sin importar quién de nosotros esté a la
cabeza vamos a seguir siempre el mismo
norte cuál es la realidad de uruguay
hoy en día en 2017 únicamente el 2 por
ciento de la electricidad que gasto vino
de fuentes no renovables como el carbón
combustibles líquidos o gas
el resto vino de centrales
hidroeléctricas vino de fuentes
renovables como el viento y el sol
nos pusimos de acuerdo
pero también pueden decirme me encanta
esto pero porque todavía sigo viendo
desastres medio inundaciones o grandes
sequías e incendios o sigo bien esas
tormentas en centroamérica que son
históricas y con una frecuencia nunca
antes vista dónde está el cambio
y la realidad es que este este impacto
negativo que estuvimos produciendo
durante muchos años es como un tren un
tren que iba muy rápido
y en el momento que nosotros nos pusimos
de acuerdo pisamos el freno pero como
saben un tren no se detiene de la noche
de la mañana sino que va frenando
lentamente hasta que se hasta que se
detiene y ahí recibe uno puede cambiar
el curso lo mismo pasa con el impacto
negativo ahora estamos esforzándonos
para poder reducir cómo crece reducir el
crecimiento que tiene y una vez que se
detenga recién vamos a poder cambiar el
rumbo e ir hacia un mundo más
sustentable
la solución no es simple para nada es
muy compleja
no podemos tomar decisiones tan
dramáticas y decir bueno quienes causan
impacto al ambiente los autos no hacemos
más autos la electricidad nos lleva más
electricidad total los hospitales que
anden como sea no es así de simple
estamos haciendo cambios
y la solución por ahí hoy en día no es
la solución ideal 100% verde que todos
desearíamos pero es una solución real a
un problema real que tenemos y todos
nosotros podemos ser parte de la
solución o parte del problema
es que medal es un ejemplo más
imagínense que llegamos a nuestras casas
hacemos algo emprendemos una luz una luz
y salimos y vamos pensando el apagón o
la apago total es una lucecita que puede
impactar que con también esta lucecita
pero ya vimos lo que pasa con lo que
pasó con ese partido de fútbol así como
nosotros pensamos hay miles o millones
de personas que piensan igual que
nosotros y que producimos
un impacto negativo aunque bastante
grande o que nosotros no lo deseemos
cuando nosotros encendemos esa lamparita
esa lamparita es electricidad que se
genera en un lado en argentina hoy en
día el 60 por ciento de la generación
proviene de estas fuentes no renovables
que estuvimos hablando de gas de
derivados del petróleo
qué quiere decir
que dejar esa lamparita prendida e irnos
estamos desperdiciando ese 60% que es un
combustible que es escaso
es limitadísimo es caro y sobre todo
produce un impacto negativo en el
ambiente
es por eso que tenemos que ser parte del
cambio
tenemos que aprovechar y ser más
conscientes de los consumos que vamos
teniendo seamos capaces de poder dejar
una huella positiva no hace falta irse
tan lejos para poder mirar los cambios
que están habiendo en el mundo no hace
falta esto y seguirse lejos bien acá en
bahía blanca lo que está pasando con la
instalación de tantos parques eólicos
así que aprovechemos aprovechemos este
momento de cambio para poder mirarlos
como faros de esperanza de un mundo más
sustentable ya que entre todos somos
capaces de dejar una huella positiva en
nuestra sociedad no solo para nosotros y
capaz no sea para nosotros pero sí para
nuestros hijos y los hijos nuestros
hijos y sobre en acciones simples
cotidianas
para dejar una huella no hace falta
construir 20.000 aerogeneradores basta
con la para una lucecita basta con
transmitir un mensaje positivo hacia
alguien
o sea que cada uno produciendo un antes
y un después en alguien es capaz de
producir un verdadero cambio nuestra
sociedad y dejar una huella más limpia
más sustentable con mejores moral con
mejor moral con mejores valores
y dejemos una huella entre todos gracias
[Aplausos]